[Musique]
cela fait plus de vingt ans que marie
marc ysaye camboulit et stéphanie
chaudron son professeur des écoles
[Musique]
chacune dans leur classe elle ressentait
des lacunes dans leur enseignement un
déclic pour changer leurs pratiques
c'est comme cela qu'est né en 2018 leur
projet pour une école heureuse
alors bonjour à tous
on fait la belle pour voir qu'il est là
ce matin
allez c'est parti on de nous comme tous
les matins les enfants commence par dire
ce qu'ils ressentent c'est la météo du
coeur même moi je suis content parce que
c'est mon papa qui m'a mené alors le
quoi de neuf
donc là vous avez cinq minutes pour dire
des choses nouvelles les choses que vous
avez envie de nous partager qui a envie
de parler
chez cote 100 m acheter un bonbon ce
temps de partage c'est ce que les
maîtresses appel l'écocitoyenneté et
c'est un des piliers de leur projet un
autre est le respect du rythme
individuel un vrai changement par
rapport à leur première année
d'enseignement
quand on a eu l'opportunité de se mettre
ensemble dans la même école donc là on a
pu vraiment
co-construire tous les outils et la mise
en place donc ce sont des espaces
ouverts chose qu'on pouvait pas faire
avant on avait du mal à ce que tous les
enfants soient en position de réussite
en position de confiance et de
progrès enfin on se rendait compte qu'on
laissait des enfants de côté et que
certains passent et ocp sans avoir les
compétences
de base requises l'intérêt c'était
vraiment de pouvoir différencier et
d'adapter chaque travail au niveau de
chaque élève et petit à petit on a
cherché à individualiser plus nos
propositions et
on a aussi eu à coeur de proposer
quelque chose un système dans lequel le
bien-être et le plaisir d'être à l'école
soit important soit une priorité et nous
on va essayer de se concentrer de
trouver le calme à l'intérieur de notre
corps
cette notion du bien-être à l'école est
très importante ce bien-être il est en
fait une recherche à la fois pour les
enfants mais aussi pour les familles
pour que les familles se sentent bien à
l'école et aussi pour nous équipes
éducatives on pense que le bien-être et
la base de tout vous faites que l'enfant
sera à même de bien apprendre de bien
évoluer si ce sens bien
s'il se sent bien à l'école des parents
qui ont aussi leur place dans l'école
pendant l'année ils peuvent venir passer
une matinée en classe et des rencontres
petit déjeuner leur sont régulièrement
proposées ce jour là la réunion est
animé par l'infirmière scolaire à la
choisit d'aborder le thème des émotions
comment réagir quand son enfant est en
colère il n'y a pas de réponse magique
mais ces discussions s'avèrent utiles on
se sent compris ou comprises est avec
toi aussi ben oui moi aussi et c'est
rassurant mais au final on en vit quand
même plus ou moins les mêmes choses
qu'on est c'est sympa de rela des
petites astuces tu
es ou juste des fois d'avoir un besoin
de se dire -
là ok je suis pas la seule c'est cool et
un dernière il voulait pas aller à
l'école par exemple là cette année je
sais qu'elle aime l'école elle aime sa
maîtresse toujours à ma maîtresse marie
elle prend du plaisir à venir à l'école
ça fait des enfants qui sont
bienveillants qui sont l écoute des
autres qui sont qui se respecte qui sont
qui nous demande si on va bien si
comment ils peuvent nous aider qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire ils sont très très
tournée vers les autres des enfants qui
progressent à leur rythme tout en étant
dans un groupe c est ce qu ils nous
raconteront de marque